where do you in the six children i know
where you lie smartest oh wait what like
i mean high maintenance wise you've got
to be the highest or no no
oh for god's sake no
i'll tell you this it's true story
that's not a story it's just a
description i was a very sweet little
boy no i was a sweet little boy
and um very sweet to my mom a real
mama's boy if you will
very sweet very nice she said i was a
mush like the others were kind of
squirrel you know fidgety and squirrel
and she said i always said i was a mush
i was the only one with sort of bright
orange hair i had this very strange name
i stuck out and then um or is it stuck
out you can't say stuck out you struck
you stuck out i just wanted to hear you
try and fix it yeah you know i was gonna
say you struck out but that's baseball
but anywho i was very sweet and then i
became
a monster at some point i don't know
what happened but i became happy i
became kind of evil when did all this
happen was there like a transformation
was it a it's my origin story and you're
gonna i'm not gonna give this away on
some chill chums oh what are you gonna
save it for my book oh yeah
i'm a real stinker by
not lettered you can't
you can't read or write i can get
someone on your first day at late night
were you already abusive to everybody
who worked for you
that's a terrible thing to say where did
you punch people for fun and did you uh
have you ever punched someone
uh yeah it's fun
it's really funny when they can't do
anything because they have to toe the
line it's hilarious
you're a sociopath oh please but like
you know when did you start like
belittling the people who oh and i'll
remind you you're under oath okay you've
had so much to drink you think i took a
note
so i think i'm a very good boss i really
do you know what after all the favors
you've done for me and all the nice
things you've done for me and stuff yeah
yeah you are i think i'm well i don't
haven't seen any of this i think i'm
back to even with you sona what do you
mean i think i've committed great crimes
um but i also think i've done a lot of
nice things too and i think we're right
now not even
no i mean because i haven't known you
that long yeah but uh you know and he
does a great job with the podcast he
does and who am i to belittle this man
who's built a wonderful matchstick home
out here and and you know it's beautiful
well i'm saying it's nice it's like a
nice arts and crafts yeah yeah i've
never heard that i just made it up it's
insulting it does sound insulting
how do i cash in this debt you just have
to stick it out for like 25 years
do that yes you can cannot do that and
then it's gonna make him it's gonna get
really uncomfortable
i'm gonna do some really nice stuff to
you for you 25 years what oh i'm going
to get you a sweet ride
i want a car
no you can't get a car i'm getting you a
sweet ride i'm i am capable of elvis
like uh you know demonstrations of
gratitude like you're gonna get me a
nickel-plated 45 caliber like he gave to
no i'm not into guns i'm not going to do
that but i would i'd get you a suite
someday i'm going to toss you the keys
of a sweet ride
it won't be my car i'm just going to
give you the keys and you're going to
drive it like you need ice cream you're
going to get arrested
excuse me
i want a car
we did a remote and you ruined my car
and then you handed me the keys to a
really shitty car that was like 20 years
old that people had clearly been
murdered in and they're going to buy
girly a car i did that because
i'm sorry
you sh i think oprah blew it because
oprah used to get her you know her
people in her audience and people in her
staff these wonderful gifts yeah i made
a
remote we shot this with cameras you can
see it online
where i totally destroyed your car you
did and debased it and made fun of you
and then said don't rail get you a new
car and got you an absolute vile piece
of crap and people think it's really
funny now if i had bought you a nice bmw
yawn no one would be talking about that
have you guys seen the bmw yawn though
it is really nice
you like you you've torn my car apart
and then i was like they'll fix it
afterwards and then jason who's here
chalemi came and he's like trying to fix
it and you actually
broke my car yeah many places that could
not be fixed and so you made it worse
than it was before carefully
disassembling a car
that's precious to someone isn't funny
smashing it
look at you you're laughing and it
happened to you and it was and come on
that car was awful it was a terrible
call like a month later it just stopped
moving on the freeway because this is
interesting what year did this remote
happen like six years ago yeah i want to
say that it's funny that i watched that
as a fan and i've sewn is great conan's
great i never thought i'd be here
loving you sona
ah
i mean help i'm helping i'm here to help
you we can help you this is like
birthing a baby it's just hard to
accomplish well no it's like it's tough
like when you
idolize someone and then they're there
it's hard to put it into words how
that's exactly i mean just don't meet
your heroes has never been more
you know and here you are in my own home
and uh how do i get you out um
and i'm wired in for sound
um no i uh i think we had a good time
and i think
i love that way to end it i love not
summing it
it up i think we had a good time no no
we had a good time and and gurley i do
think
i'll say this you give as good as you
get buddy
you know i i wasn't that way till till i
met you that's not true you've always
had this ability no tell me tell me
you're not you're not a wise crack and
you know you you've always been able to
i wisecrack with not at i had to learn
to add you know what i mean that's good
i had to defend myself i think i am like
your little brother that had to learn to
put his dukes up he never did
to this day i wail on him and he just
keeps his hands by his side he's a
pacifist he was made a huge mistake he
declared himself a pacifist when he was
five and i said that's real funny and
then i hit him with a trash can
um you're awful yeah worst guy ever
sorry justin you had it coming oh
justin's the nicest too well we'll see
he's probably good
that's cool ben you know i used to do
that i used to tell justin if you don't
straighten up you're going to end up
like ben he'd be like who's ben let's
say i would look wisely in the backyard
towards a pile of leaves turns a pile of
chicken feet
and i would just say you know he didn't
buy it because my other brothers and
sisters tried to go along with it but
they didn't pick up on the name that i
was using they'd be like that's right
you don't want to end up like nick and
i'm like [ __ ] oh it's got to be ben it's
got to be ben yes this had to be ben
yeah you have to have a consistency
there
well i gotta pee
all right yeah why don't you go you're
gonna have a good time um
we're gonna cut you off soon you should
and uh i just wanna thank everyone for
checking out this very special episode
yeah of chill chums in the backyard
gurley's wonderful home
here in pasadena yep we're in the wild
we never may never be heard from again
oh we might not yeah we're gonna we're
gonna pitch a tent in camp here tonight
right chums no pitch to 10 10 minutes
ago oh come on
wait that's right there's no microphone
there no else exactly oh i know what i
meant by that and i don't want anyone to
get offended as i really did pitch a
tent oh did you oh i thought you got
aroused after you told your ducks
no that's what i meant wait i really did
pitch a 10. is somebody getting a honk
job or not i can flip back and forth now
wait did you did you say that you
pitched to 10. oh yeah i pitched a 10.
oh that's not offensive no but i pitched
a 10. oh my god i'm really offended
no no no no i meant i pitched a tent oh
that's fine okay yeah and then i pitched
a tent yeah oh my god you're under
arrest yeah you just don't know well i'm
rocking a sundial
get the [ __ ] out of here
go have yourself
this little pee pee time for gourley
time come with me that's a little
spin-off podcast